[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing draco's lackey
vincent crabbe of the crab and goyal duo
more specifically however we're going to
be discussing crab
in relation to a powerful piece of dark
magic the spell
that is fiend fire vincent crabbe
was a pureblood wizard born in the year
he came from a long line of dark wizards
and death eaters
and his father crab senior is mentioned
in the series
though crab came from darker beginnings
that didn't mean that he wasn't allowed
to study
at hogwarts unsurprisingly crab was
sorted into slytherin
when he got to the school and formed a
particularly close bond
with fellow slytherin gregory coyle and
ringleader
draco malfoy in the year that umbridge
became headmistress
goyle and crabb joined malfoy in the
inquisitorial squad
ratting out his fellow students for
refusing to acknowledge the new
hogwarts rules however at this point in
time
crab's actions were certainly more
innocent as he grew older
and became a man the state of the
wizarding world was at stake
which forced a lot of students to pick a
side crab chose the side of evil
of voldemort and it was ultimately this
decision
that turned him from petulant child to a
very corrupt
twisted young man in fact when the
cairos were teaching at hogwarts
were given a glance of the type of
person that he had become
amicus the bloke he teaches what used to
be defense against the dark arts
except now it's just the dark arts we're
supposed to practice the cruciatus curse
on people who've earned detentions what
harry ron and hermione's united voices
echoed up and down the passage we're
supposed to practice the cruciatus curse
on people who've earned detentions i
refuse to do it
some people are into it though crap and
goyle love it
first time they've ever been top in
anything i expect
the tragedy of crab is that he never
even really stood a chance
he came from a family of death eaters
and right from the start he became a
part of a friend group
that made all the wrong choices to quote
dumbledore
it is our choices harry that show what
we truly are
far more than our abilities and crab
made a lot
of the wrong choices by the time crab's
final year at hogwarts rolled around
he had become a fully fledged dark
wizard in his own right
not just the son of one this ultimately
led to him acting in opposition to the
trio
as well as turning on a large number of
the students that he had grown up with
on may the 2nd 1998 in the room of
requirement
crabb ends up casting one of the most
powerful dark curses
in the wizarding world fiend fire it was
not normal fire
crab had used a curse of which harry had
no knowledge
as they turned a corner the flames
chased them as though they were alive
sentient intent upon killing them now
the fire was mutating
forming a gigantic pack of fiery beasts
flaming serpents
chimeras and dragons rose and fell and
rose again
and the detritus of centuries on which
they were feeding was thrown up in the
air into their fanged mouths
tossed high on clawed feet before being
consumed by the inferno
fiend fire is a piece of extremely
advanced dark magic
a spell which produces enchanted flames
of an enormous scale
that essentially destroy anything in its
path often taking the form of gigantic
fiery beasts i guess now the question is
how did crab
cast it fiendfire seems like a type of
spell that would be reserved for
extremely powerful dark wizards
like voldemort and grindelwald i know
that i was personally quite surprised
to see the spell being produced by
someone who has often been painted out
to be quite incompetent
up to this point this is probably the
most powerful spell
performed by anyone at any point
so how did he do it isn't crab just
malfoy's lackey
here's the thing of the two crab and
goyal crab
was certainly more talented
interestingly though the film seemed to
give
us the opposite impression crab was more
than meets the eye
and it turns out that he wasn't a
complete simpleton in fact he became
quite skilled at producing dark magic
as he grew older we even see him cast an
effective avada kadavra
and ron a spell which requires a fair
bit of concentration
and skill crap wheeled round and
screamed avada kadavra again
ron lept out of sight to avoid the jet
of green light
the wandless malfoy cowered behind a
three-legged wardrobe
as hermione charged towards them hitting
goyle with a stunning spell
as she came given his death eater
heritage i think the crab
must have been taught an awful lot of
dark magic at home
in addition to the magic that he was
learning at hogwarts
not only that but he learned quite a lot
from the cairos eager at the opportunity
to learn more about the dark arts after
the fiasco in the room of requirement
ends harry surmises that crab must have
learned how to cast the fiend fire curse
from the carrows fiend fire cursed fire
it's one of the substances that destroy
horcruxes
but i would never ever have dared use it
it's so dangerous
how did grab know how to must have
learned from the carrots
said harry grimly shamey wasn't
concentrating when they mentioned how to
stop it
really said ron whose hair like
hermione's was singed
and whose face was blackened if he
hadn't tried to kill us all
i'd be quite sorry he was dead and
that's another thing i need to touch on
here
crab didn't exactly survive his brief
stint at casting fiend fire
you see crab was taught dark magic very
quickly
and though he was able to cast fiend
fire which is impressive by itself it
doesn't mean
he was able to control it crab's
understanding of magic was very
one-dimensional
and that's because he didn't really make
a proper effort to learn
until later on in life even as late as
sixth year
crab still had a hard time with his
defense against the dark arts owl
as revealed by snape if your friends
crab and goyle intend to pass their
defense against the dark arts owl this
time around
they will need to work a little harder
than they are doing at present
and it appears that even when he's
casting these powerful spells
he still fails to understand basic
things like following orders
or repercussions stop the dark lord
wants him alive
so i'm not killing him am i but if i can
i will the dark lord wants him dead
anyway what's the diff it's that
mudblood
avada kadavra in short crab learned a
lot of dark magic
very quickly and this ultimately led to
his own demise
he knew how to cast these dark spells
but he didn't quite understand what he
was casting which led to his inability
to control
his own fiend fire when crabb attempted
to kill harry in the room of requirement
his last words were like it hot scum
which is of course painfully ironic
given that the only person properly
subjected to the curse
was himself in a room full of objects in
a sick and twisted way i'm willing to
bet that amicus and alectocaro
knew what they were doing when they
taught crab how to only
partially perform fiend fire they
probably thought that it would be funny
to teach this evil albeit misguided
student
a bunk spell effectively sending him on
a suicide mission
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content
please remember to like the video and
subscribe
to the channel until next time it is
important
to fight and fight again and keep
fighting for only then
can evil be kept at bay though never
quite eradicated
[Music]
you